and today we're going to talk about some
fun kubernetes things and that I have
learned the hard way
a little bit about me my name is David
my accent is Scottish I'm from a study
called Glasgow
I am the founder of the Rockwood Academy
this is a YouTube channel that focuses
on making Cloud native and kubernetes
easier for people
and through series like clustert has
anyone seen clustered before
all right just a few of you for the rest
of you
um it's a live stream that we do quite
regularly where you get to watch me cry
a lot
I also am the organizer of a new
kubernetes conference in Scotland her
first one is actually on Monday it's
called coup puddle and so I'm looking
forward to that too
and generally my mission is just to make
this easier for people and Cloud native
and kubernetes is is pretty hard so if
you're here and you're in that space
yeah congratulations on commiserations
the custard is a relatively simple idea
it was around two years ago where I had
this silly idea that I'm I'm quite good
with kubernetes I've operated kubernetes
now for around six seven years and I
thought how can we help people prepare
to do the cka the ckad the cks ETC and I
don't know about you but I'm a very
tactile learner I don't really learn
from reading a lot I learned by getting
my hands on a keyboard and trying to do
something and I thought well why don't I
do that in a live stream and then it's
available for other people to see how
these situations are debuffed this is
really important on clustered like there
are a lot of ways to break a kubernetes
cluster but we do see repeat breaks and
what's really fascinating is that each
person that joins me on the show they
have a different way that they first
understand the landscape so what's wrong
and then start to debug it and it's
actually those thought processes that
they share with people on the stream
that's more important than the actual
fixing itself the fixing it's just
something that's kind of mildly
entertaining as you go along
so it should be simple your mission is
to take a deployment which is running a
bespoke clustered application there's a
V1 and a V2 all you need to do is change
that deployment from B1 to V2
easy right well it turns out it's not
that easy as I said there are a lot a
lot of ways to break the kubernetes
cluster and what I want to do with this
talk is just guide you through some of
the core domains that I feel people
should be more familiar with when
operating kubernetes and some tips along
the way
now here's something that I've also
learned after I think we're in 50
episodes people are very mean
uh
people don't just put titles and config
files and call the cluster broken we've
seen people actually downgrade the
kiblet on a machine by about 20 or 30
versions
I don't know about you I've never
thought to run cubelet-version to check
what version is running on my cluster I
made some assumptions assumptions that
clearly we can't make because we don't
trust people
we've also had people recompile the API
server actually write their own code
compile it and ship it onto my clusters
and I don't like these people
however we've had people comment saying
well these aren't real world and I
actually disagree now sure human error
is a big part of operating kubernetes
mistakes happen tables happen and we
revert commits and maybe we got the
rebates wrong how many times have you
had a commit message or a code change
that's got those three little less than
adults happens all the time but security
and your security posture intrusion are
real concerns people can get access to
your cluster now with the downgrade
accupulate by 20 or 30 versions probably
not but would they inject their own API
server to log stuff to some remote
location potentially
so well some of the scenarios and some
of the breaks that we've seen may not be
something that you deal with on a
regular basis we do need to understand
what we're working with
so I'm going to cheat for the next three
minutes and show you a short clip of an
episode of clustered you will hear me
swear I'm really sorry
um clustered gets very frustrating and
this was a particularly long episode and
but I'm going to show you a small clip
just now
yeah we still have no cluster DNS
50s has endpoint uh look at that after a
foreign
[Music]
s
are configured to run the DNS
it's always DNS
all right did we miss something
I'm going to say chi let's I'm going to
jump onto cluster uh 14.
and see what's different
what about uh
yeah these are the exact same fail so he
told us to look in the court DNS config
and then there's nothing wrong with the
chord DNS clip that's just cruel
and there's a few pixels
this is a white space editor in the core
DNS config I would be amazing frustrated
it might not be a white space error
yeah um
he's mocking us now because he said
you're jumping back and forward showed a
slight difference
this number seems arbitrary yeah
I'm assuming
there's like a weird bug and I'm sure
he's found it because he works at
Skyscanner and they've got a level of
skill that most people don't have
something to do with this number going
so high is maybe causing it to load an
old config map in the pods
or something I don't really
know
but the number being so high worries me
um
but we're now at the stage where I have
to go and pick up my daughter so yeah
I'm just going to bring guy in to tell
us what wonderful magic I wish to play
yeah this is yeah all right guys
really honest
uh so when you were jumping back and
forth between the working complex and
the non-working contract
um if you look really hard at the sea in
front of the in the kubernetes conflict
oh
the sea
uh yeah
it's a character which looks a lot like
what so the kubernetes plugin became
authoritative for
letter that looks like see luster.local
I hate that guy
's a good friend of mine uh he's from
Glasgow too he does work at Skyscanner
he's also the co-chair of stego Auto
scaling so when I invited him on I
thought we're going to get a really cool
Auto skill in the bug
we got a Unicode book
um
what I like about this clip is
I was beginning to challenge really
silly things I thought that 800 000 was
going to cause some sort of integer
overflow why of course it doesn't make
any sense like
let's go like it's not going to happen
unless we use an Aboriginal small hint
but you get into this mindset when
you're debugging and sometimes you just
don't know what to look at um so I think
it's just important to highlight that
well I have a lot of experience
sometimes if you just don't know the
answer you're never going to see it
um yeah so there's lots of episodes like
that
sadly
now there were no rules in clustered
that has no changed we no longer allow
you any good breaks well they were fun
the first time it's not something we
want to encourage
and the only other ruling cluster today
is no saturation attacks and we had one
break where they actually filled the
desk so the machine wouldn't start and I
can't fix a cluster if the machine isn't
online
yeah so a couple of rules but really if
you want to join me on cluster feel free
to talk to me after but you can break
anything in the kubernetes control plane
and I'll sit down with someone else from
the kubernetes community again that
could be one of you here and we'll try
and fix it on our live stream
funnily enough it's quite hard to find
people that are willing to sit in the
live stream for 90 minutes and fix
something when they have no idea what's
wrong
so I also think it's important to
highlight the failure is just how we
learn and you know I think we need to
get better about talking about failure
especially senior and principal
Engineers you know it's really important
that we are more public about the things
that we we don't know the things that we
learn and share that with people to set
better Norms in the future
and I'm going to guide you now through
the road to kubernetes and over the last
50-ish episodes and I've seen lots of
different breaks I wanted to distill
them down into around nine tips and
tricks across the different domains that
you need to understand in order to
operate kubernetes successfully
and of course we have to start with
Linux kubernetes runs on Linux I guess
it runs on Windows I don't do that I
can't help you with that but I can help
you with Linux
oh yeah I forgot that this is a much
smaller clip and it's just to set the
scene for something so it's just a
minute long and then we'll I'll talk
about what we've just seen
permission oh
and you've hit your first snag there you
go
okay make it plus six
yeah
I need my auto complete stuff I'm lost
you didn't install fish while you're
here too
I can I can type one
oh okay okay
it's an interesting start
yes yes do an Ellis show a on user bin
uh change password probably just in
change mode
oh Father you don't even have tab
completion
but hey we'll make it one if you're
doing I think that's oh wait because you
can't come on
yeah
just look at the whole slash Advan is
there anything we should
well LS is obviously
all right
so this was another really served up at
this episode
um this was cedaro Labs who actually
have their own kubernetes based
operating system so they understand
Linux and kubernetes extremely well they
write their own pet one all the services
on the machine speak over grpc and the
kubernetes stuff is all running in
containers it's very Advanced very smart
team
the other team that broke this cluster
was red hat
they also know a few things about Linux
and this was in the first two minutes of
this episode and you can see from a
screenshot you know Green is a usual
symbol for us that tells us that a fail
is executable
and if you look at the white ones in
here this is extremely intentional
they have no chemod they have no change
attributes no Cube admin no Cube control
why they stuck OC on there I have no
idea
they have no SCP so they can't even
transfer fails remotely back onto the
machine and they have no peril
who knows how to fix chimod when you
can't execute chemod without chemod
I do know
um
so the easiest way to do this would be
in Peril that would have been what I
went for and I suppose you could maybe
do this with python too but Peril has
really closed uh direct support to other
executables on the machine so you can
use chemot however they removed the
executable bit from peril
you can't do much without Cube control
and change attributes is something we've
seen on clustered more than once as well
who knows what attributes are on a Linux
fail system
right there's like two hands
and so we all know you can do a chemod
which allows us to change read write and
executable bits and one other I wouldn't
touch on that just now and but there's
also something called attributes which
allows you to modify things at a much
deeper level one of them being
immutability you can actually Mark fails
as immutable on one episode of clustered
we've seen someone Mark the entire logs
directory as immutable
so people were trying to debug a broken
cluster going where are all the logs
and none of the processes could write a
lot and that was particularly evil too
so we see a lot of stuff
um but it's through this misery that we
face on cluster that we learn really
cool things
so how do we fix chemod without chemod
well it turns out you can actually use
the dynamic Linker directly
so you can find that the ldlinux.so on a
machine and you can pass it another
binary and it will execute it without
checking for executable bit meaning you
can chemod the Chipmunk so nice tip
fail attributes uh once you know they're
there they're much easier to understand
you can use LS attribute and change
attributes the only one that we've
really seen cause any destruction on
clustered is the immutability flag so if
you ever see that eye on attributes then
you know that the sum process is not
going to be able to rate your fail or
directory Etc
no I said Serendipity earlier there was
one other very very certain type of this
episode there was an episode with Crest
Nova who knows Chris
all right a couple of hats Robert Thomas
Stromberg
okay let me fill you in Chris Nova is a
security researcher engineer currently
at twilio formerly Google heptel really
knows our stuff
also a bit of a kernel hacker
so we were expecting big things
Thomas Stromberg also formerly Google
that intrusion detection was a
maintainer of many Cube and has worked
directly on the kubernetes components
those two just happened to be on this
episode together but under no under no
other circumstances would anyone else
who fixed Chrissy's broken cluster
Chris was using LD preload to remove
ciscals from all executables on the
machine use an ebpf to hide a process on
the machine that was doing naughty stuff
in the background
when you run Cube control get pods it
just displayed a big message saying this
cluster is essentially screwed
however
Thomas has done intrusion detection at
Google
and the first thing he did on this
machine was installed something called
Swift kit and I'm going to ask you to
raise your hands one more time but I
don't expect to see any who's heard of
Swift kit
why would you right well Swift cat is
this really old piece of software that
runs on Windows BSD Mac and Linux it's
been used for intrusion detection for
nearly 20 years and it has really cool
tools that allow you to get very low
level with the fail system and the
kernel one of those tools is fls
fls will actually take a snapshot of all
the changes on a fail system for any
given period of time
so he logs on installs lift kit run as
fls command and he had a directory with
a whole bunch of blobs that told him
everything Chris had done in that
cluster in the last 24 hours
it was pretty neat
no of course some things are rather
opaque right we see the hcd changed but
what changed
we had no idea so
with regards to modifying system D unit
fails modifying cubic configurations API
servers container D configuration all of
that was just right in front of them but
obviously anything within the kubernetes
API we still have to revert to
traditional debugging techniques however
fls is a cool tool and the fact that it
runs everywhere is pretty awesome and
you can run that on your own machine
it's amazing how much information you
get you can even see even files have
been deleted and there is the potential
to restore some deleted fails and but
there's a whole bunch of semantics on
how that works and whether whether it
will be successful
so that's our Linux tips we're going to
move on to the other Dark Art of
kubernetes which is networking
unfortunately if you're operating a
kubernetes cluster you do have to get
very comfortable with networking because
there's a lot of magic happening
especially with modern advancements in
ebpf and XDP through cni projects like
psyllium
now if you're using one of these new
fancy shiny cnis which I assume we all
are these days we have core we have
Network and V1 networking policies these
are the base networking policies that
are in your kubernetes cluster and of
course we need to be able to understand
them and those are a good first place to
check however
all these other cnis now bring in their
own custom resources celium has cluster
Network policies no celium network
policies and sodium cluster-wide Network
policies
and this year
they released local redirect policies
and so there's a lot of ways to adjust
how your traffic is working within the
cluster
what's also quite special about what
psyllium are offering is it's not just
L4 based policies but they offer L7
based policies what that means is you
have actual protocol awareness first a
set HTTP DNS I think some databases are
supported where you can actually
intermittently break traffic to certain
domains or ports or even block
individual DNS queries against a subset
of the internet
lots of stuff lots of magic and you
might not know where to get started
next the thing I hate most about
kubernetes and there are a lot of them
but this one really frustrates me
because it's one of these things that
passes the eyeball test
who's ever changed the DNS policy on a
pod
okay well there's a DNS policy called
default do you know which the default
DNS policy is it's not default
why
the default policy actually tells the
cluster to use the default DNS
resolution of the host typically systemd
result d
the default kubernetes DNS policy is
cluster first
now I hope one day that can be changed
but unfortunately that's which is where
we are and again we learned this the
hard way someone changed the DNS policy
in a pod I'm scanning it I'm going to
default sure whatever adjust the default
and and of course we had no internal DNS
resolution within that cluster
also iptables as a fundamental skill
still even with some of these ebpf and
XDP tools within our cluster and could
proxy is still heavy heavily relies on
iptables or EBT plus NF tables Etc
but there's also another part of the
networking stack which I learned the
hard way on clustered
who knows what the TC command is
oh a couple of hands there you go I know
now
but the TC command is called traffic
control and that allows you to apply
quality of service and to different
types of requests within your cluster so
what actually happens is someone used
traffic control to drop a 95 rejection
rate on all HTTP traffic within my
cluster
people are cruel
so I'm looking at IP tables like because
I know iptos I can run I can list all
the chains I can list all the rules but
I had no idea about TC
and then we've got evpf evpf is a
phenomenal tool and I'm going to talk
more about it later but it's also rather
opaque when someone runs something with
ebpf in your cluster you're not
necessarily sure that it's there it's
very hard to discover and find and even
harder to tweak and modify unless you
know exactly what's been done but the
technology itself is pretty special
now if you want to make your networking
life easier on kubernetes and I know the
screenshot's not that big but it's also
not that important um but you have this
tool called Hubble from psyllium this is
a user interface that runs in your
cluster why do we need a user interface
for networking because you can run Cube
control get net policy
npccmps that's all the network policies
within the celium stack and you'll list
them all but it's actually really
difficult to have a visualization of
what traffic is actually moving around
your cluster you can read all the ammo
but you're never I mean I'm not a visual
learner I can't visualize things in my
mind but this UI is essential and can be
essential so you can see all the pods
all the services you can see arrows that
show which ones are speaking to which
and then there's even tools which you'll
see in just a moment that allow you to
modify that as well so Hubble is a
fantastic tool and but only if you're
using psyllium unfortunately
there's also a Hubble CLI so I like to
use Hubble as a UI to understand the the
kind of spread of services and what's
happening but if I want to be able to
start debugging problems I want to start
understanding individual flows you can
drop down to Hubble observe
Hubble observe you can see here we're
doing a filter for drop packets and then
I'm doing an additional pipe to grip
because I'm looking for things that are
messing around with postgres instead of
my cluster and this was actually a
cluster that I broke for the psyllium
team
um and I used their local redirect
policies had been released for about 48
hours maybe a week at the max so I threw
one in and what the local redirect
policy should be used for is if you want
to run like DNS caches across all of
your nodes in your clusters well they
don't go over the networking stack then
you can local redirect all DNS requests
to the local pod
however I was a bit more sneaky and said
all traffic going to postgres let's just
throw it to fluent D instead
plenty doesn't listen on Port 5432 so
um they were able to run Hubble observe
and actually find oh look why is our
postgres traffic going to the Food Depot
so really good ability to understand
individual flows um I love the Hubble UI
and the CLI both phenomenal tools
and because isovalent haven't given us
enough awesome stuff they've given us
one more thing
the celium editor
so you can go to editor.cellium.io
and you can actually upload your network
policy documents networking V1 documents
or celium custom resources and it will
visualize them for you
it will also allow you to make
modifications to it again it's hard to
see on a screenshot but you can click
allow DNS resolution in this pod but
only to certain domains or you can click
allow this pod to speak to this pod over
here on this port so you can get this
really visual interface to just point
and click and then you get the
declarative networking policy at the
other end you stick it into get you've
set up some sort of get UPS Pipeline and
then you're laughing so I always
recommend people use Hubble whenever
possible and even if you're not using
Hubble you can still use the celium
editor with network and V1 policies so
really really cool tool
next at City
anybody like it City
no of course not
well this is not a real statistic but
you know as a quick straw poll with the
people that have been on clustered you
know what we've seen is that any time
there is a cluster an LCD break people
are pretty unhappy because people don't
really understand how to operate Etc
we're kind of spoiled because we don't
really we don't really need to worry
about it too much because we have all
these managed kubernetes Services now
but if you're doing something on your
own bare metal or you're doing hybrid
cloud architectures and you build
probably at some point have to worry
about operating entity
because it doesn't scale geographically
you have to run multiple of these and
it's very difficult
and I always do a pre-show interview
with everyone that joins me on cluster
to try and make them feel less stressed
about being unclustered but I always say
what's the one thing you don't want to
see today and it's always at City nobody
wants to see an Etsy break but they do
happen
so
I can't obviously tell you how to
operate etcd and but I can tell you some
of the things we've learned one is
entity has something called an alarm
now entity is rather configurable you
can specify the quota for the storage
backend so that is I only ever want to
allow etcd to store up to 512 Mega data
and then it will start blocking All
Rights
this is interesting because Cube control
get still continues to work your cluster
still continues to work pods just won't
be scheduled if they disappear and you
can't create any new deployments Etc
but everything appears to be okay except
for the right operations
now you have to then run it's you know
you have to change the storage quota
first but that doesn't actually solve
the alarm
so you can restart LCD with a new code
there's loads of space you think things
should be working
but you have to manually list the alarms
and disarm them every time something
happens with an entity
there's a lot of configuration here you
can actually change the max right we're
seeing people try to break at CD by
pushing down two Meg blobs to it which
actually does do some damage and but
again everything is configurable and you
can make this work to your own detriment
I guess
it's hard
number two we've seen someone enable
encryption on our LCD cluster
unclustered
anyone know what happens when you enable
encryption on your LCD cluster
your API server can no longer read
anything inside of ETD because enable an
encryption does not actually encrypt all
of the old data you have to do this
manually
now there is a nice easy way at the
bottom there where you can enable dual
mode which I'll show you the config for
in a second but this allows you to
support encrypted and unencrypted data
and HTT is a migration path and then you
can literally just do a get sequence all
spread out as Json and then pipe it
straight into group control replace to
re-encrypt all that data
which is a nice way of handling it
uh but yeah that was a tough episode too
and at one point during this episode I
was actually using the LCD command line
and manually trying to inject everything
into sat encrypted it was not a good
look
um I don't think I have a tip to be
honest but I'm going to talk about it
anyway and I'll show the gamma config
frame when it's interested
another really
horrible break we've seen with Etsy D is
we spin up our clusters with a single
LCD node
so it doesn't run in any sort of high
availability capacity and the breaker
just did one command
LTD control member add 0.0.0.0
not a real IP address however that one
simple change
turns entity and to Cluster mode and
then of course it's not got Quorum
because that machine doesn't exist it
never came online but immediately I've
lost any ability to create a rate to
etcd at all
you know what the fix is
delete etcd and start again
and you need to have snapshots snapshot
on your LCD cluster is is just crucial
when operating kubernetes
um so the only way we could fix that was
to uninstall it reinstall it restore
from the snapshot and away we went so
there you go man city is fun
now where are we going with this
this is just a bit of a word cloud from
all the breaks that I've seen over the
50 episodes you can imagine there are a
lot of ways to break kubernetes
um we've seen an interesting container D
break
continuity has a really cool feature
called aliasin this allows you to pull
images from an alternative location that
are not the ones within the Manifest
so what we've seen someone do was run
their own
container image registry uh have
continuity forward all requests or
Docker Hub to it and all the images were
seated with bad strength so every time I
thought I was pulling an official nginx
image from Docker Hub I was actually
getting some random image from them
nothing was working
um and it's again who knew this feature
existed well I do know
we've also seen people swap out the CRI
so you know most of these clusters are
Cube admin clusters so they run
container Breed by default we actually
seen someone replace it with Docker
which sounds fine right
however there is an interesting bug or a
feature I'm not quite sure which
where
we're going to need a little bit more
context for this one kubernetes control
plane has something called a static
manifest a static manifest is a gamble
fail that lives on the control plane
nodes and the couplet starts these pods
for you for cube ADM or admin clusters
this runs all of the control plane
components the scheduler the API server
and the controller managers Etc
there's a bug feature with the docker
CRI where if you put the namespace in
that to be a namespace that doesn't
exist
the cubelet will still run the container
but you can run Cube control get
namespaces and the namespace isn't there
you can run Cube control get pods all
namespaces then that pod is not there
you actually have the ability with the
docker CRI to hide an arbitrary workload
inside of someone's cluster by typing a
namespace
so yeah maybe not use Docker as a CRI
we've seen a lot of systemd attacks and
by attacks I just mean people run system
D to orchestrate malicious processes on
the host and they give them interesting
names that pass the iPhone test like DMS
resolver or systemd debugger or whatever
things that you scam and you just go ah
I'm sure that's fine because who knows
all of the system D components there's
just too many
so yeah there there's lots of things
that we've seen on clustered
and to iterate and what I said earlier
we only learn this stuff the hard way
nobody sits down reading the kubernetes
documentation looking for loopholes and
the docker CRI for hiding malicious
plots nobody sits there going what
happens if you downgrade the cube at 20
versions it's only when these things
happen to us that we learn all these
valuable lessons so people shouldn't
feel bad or feel that they are not you
know capable kubernetes operators just
because you haven't come across this
stuff in the wild
and I feel that we have a bit of a
problem in our industry with hero
culture and that we celebrate people
that work long hours we celebrate people
that seem to know everything we
celebrate people that come in and swoop
in and save projects however we actually
need to dismantle that a little bit and
again I encourage everyone here in their
office to say I don't know as much as
possible especially in front of Junior
engineers and people that are learning
so we all find this difficult and I
encourage you if you want to to learn
more in public when you find something
cool with kubernetes that breaks post it
on Twitter you don't need to tape up a
big massive blog post it's 5000 words
you can even just share a guest and post
that
and but it's only through you know we
all have our own unique circumstances
our own production looks different
nobody's production is the same we're
always going to run into different
things so I encourage you all to share
as much as possible
now what am I learning next well I
mentioned ebpf earlier I generally
believe this is the most valuable thing
that anyone operating kubernetes could
be learning right now
and at least this is my opinion
and the reason that I believe this is
well it gives us the ability to run
Arbiter code within the kernel
if you remember monitoring any Linux
system I'm not even talking about
containers and kubernetes now anything
we used to have agents for PHP we had
agents for Ruby we had agents for python
all of these different run times needed
to instrument it differently
however with ebpf because we can hook
into the kernel and assist calls we can
actually understand all of these
runtimes
with a single language
so we no longer need to go and get the
datadog PHP agent we can just install
some sort of ebpf agent and then have it
right to some location
it also gives us the ability to
understand tracing within our kernel so
we can get networking understanding for
latency for all requests it's really
just a little bit Magic
it's also safe and secure although this
has been challenged by you know people
trying to break it as often as possible
and but we essentially are encouraged to
believe that we have a Sandbox within
the kernel that will never crash because
of the restrictions the kernel places on
the language that we use to rate our
ebpf programs
now we already have a lot of ebpf out
there already
I mentioned Salim a lot it's a fantastic
project and it relies heavily on XDP and
ebpf
Falco from systek is another really cool
project it allows us to write rules to
actually monitor for our syscalls being
run across all of our cluster
so you know your applications better
than anyone else you know what your
application is supposed to be doing
should it be banned in a socket on a low
port number probably not so we can
actually monitor for this now of course
hopefully we have runtime profiles that
don't allow that at all but I haven't
seen a lot of that in the world so using
file code to understand what's happening
within your clusters and having that log
these rules somewhere just gives you a
lot more visibility
Inspector Gadget by the team at convoke
now at Microsoft is another awesome
project it gives us tools to actually
debug and work with our cluster as well
it will allow you to run code for then
um pods to monitor for ports what if
there's an application running you don't
know what port it's on I mean we all set
the container port in our pod but do you
know it does nothing
nothing at all all it does is provide an
alias so that in your service you can
use the poor the port name rather than
the port number
but that doesn't allow the Pod to open
something on that port and it doesn't
actually affect any traffic so it could
say Port 80 but your service is actually
running on Port 4000 and you would never
know
this Patrick Gadget gives us a tool
where we can actually say lesson for all
Banes in this part and tell me what
ports get opened and it spits them
straight back out I actually broke a
cluster for ebpf Day last year for the
Microsoft team and I changed the port to
see how quickly they would get it and
they fired out their Inspector Gadget
bind tool pretty quickly
pexy is a really cool project it's open
source but they were recently bought by
a New Relic so I don't know what that
means but pixie is is really cool and it
gives you monitoring for all run things
by just running abpf code and exports
Prometheus endpoints you can scrape it
all you don't need to change your code
it hooks in at the kernel level
now what is quite common with all of
these tools is that they layer on and
build and top of the BCC or BPF examples
so there is github.com iovisor there's a
project called BCC it has a whole bunch
of tools I think there's at least 13
maybe even more but some of them are
listed here exact Snoop you can run exec
snip on any Linux machine and it will
tell you every time someone executes a
command
you can fail for that to look for
processes that have the set uidbit as
one or sudo so you can actually emit
events every time someone elevates their
privileges over on your machine
or you could just look for people
running Cube control and spell something
in slack doing hey someone just ran Cube
control what you did
entirely up to you
there's also IO snip this will allow you
to monitor all file operations with on a
machine without having to instrument
anything as well there's open Snap which
shows you every time a process opens a
fail so you can see we're getting all of
this visibility that we just didn't have
access to before
and then the three at the bottom are the
TCP staff you can actually monitor all
of the TCP traffic within your cluster
with a single command
so these tools are just phenomenal
and I believe ebpf does change
everything uh do we have time for the
demo
no I'll keep time for for questions but
if you want to see a demo of ebpf I do
have these Labs available here
um on a struct that give you a real
kubernetes environment and the challenge
is clustered so if I export my Cube
config
and Cube control get part
we have a broken kubernetes cluster here
I prepared six of these
and they're not publicly available yet
but my plan is to do that really really
soon but if you feel like a bit of a
challenge while you're here at the
conference and drop me a DM on Twitter
see me walking around come up and speak
to me and I will get you access and you
can try and work through these
challenges yourself
some of them are easy some of them are
cruel so just check it out and let me
know how you get on
no this is the kubernetes risk pyramid
uh what I'm trying to show here is the
evpf allows us to instrument and
understand every layer in this pyramid
now the highest risk we have with
operating kubernetes is at the Linux
level most of the attacks are going to
try and attack the host rather than
coming through the workloads on the
cluster however that is also a potential
and eppf gets us on Parallel of
observability into that Linux kernel
imagine using Bank Snoop an exec Snoop
and uh monitor for specifics just calls
on that host and logging them somewhere
again you probably know what kind of
commands and things you expect to run on
your machines so really tailor that to
make sure that you have intrusion
detection across the entire line of
Stack
moving up the pyramid we have lateral
movement from a pod
should someone actually get access to
your application we hope that they're
stuck in that container and they can't
do anything however we do have things
like default service account binding
which may allow them to speak to the
kubernetes API and depending on the
privileges on runtime security profile
for the Pod they may be able to do more
so make sure that you understand and
apply Network policies whenever possible
because this is how you're going to get
detection for that lateral movement why
is this part suddenly speaking to my API
server if I don't want it to or why is
it sending PG dump commands to a
postgres container that it shouldn't be
speaking to so just make sure that you
understand that landscape
and then the lowest risk but the most
dangerous risk is well what if we have a
container bracket and again it's almost
through runtime profiles and tools like
Falco that we can actually get real-time
detection for that now container
breakouts are extremely unlikely as long
as you apply all the sensible defaults
however there is still a risk that we
need to be aware of
if you want to learn more about ebpf
Brandon Gregg is really driving the
awareness of this project forward and
and building some really cool tools on
top of it so check out Brandon Greg's
blog
I've already mentioned the BCC project
but there are lots of examples in that
repository so if you've got an idea for
a tool that could leverage EBP ebpf like
the one I use a lot is just check for
pseudo access and Cube control access on
a machine and have it log somewhere you
can go to that repository go into the
tools folder you'll see the exact snip
it's python code you just start hacking
it to only filter for the commands or
the processes that you need and then you
run that Epps program across your
infrastructure and you get this
observability
now ebpf kept
this one is dangerous
this is from the team at data dog who
decided Well ebpf gives us
interest and Powers within a machine
could we build a root kit with it
the answer was yes
this is our I'm not going to say 100
because I can't see 100 but I could see
undetectable rootkit using ebpf it's
very difficult to understand this is
running on a machine through traditional
tools you actually need more evpf to
understand that there's other ebpf
happening
um but you can check out this project
and there are some demos on YouTube
where they walk through at conferences
and but it's just scary and exciting
that kind of cross-section between the
two but very cool project
all right so I would love to speak to
people afterwards and know where you
what users are learning and what you
just find interesting there's a lot out
there we've all seen the cncf landscape
right
there's lots of tools there's hundreds
of tools maybe even thousands of tools
so well ebpf is interesting for me I'm
always curious to see what other people
are learning and what they're finding
them interesting too
thank you so much for your time I'm
happy to take any questions
that's it thanks
[Applause]
any questions
oh yeah
have a look at tetragon yet yes I have
uh I know there's been a lot of not
complaints but maybe backlash against
isovalent for releasing a product that
doesn't quite do what they say however I
think it's a really good first step and
I'm excited to see where the project
goes and I think it is going to bring a
new level of understanding to things
happening in our cluster so I'm excited
by it and I played with it but I haven't
deployed it in production yet
have you
nice
yeah
so the question was what do I think
about service meshes you mentioned
thinker D do they help us understand and
control traffic within a cluster 100 I
use zenkodi on every single cluster and
because you get automatic mtls between
all of the connections within your
cluster and I think that's really
important and we always have this
concept or we have this naive assumption
that traffic within our cluster is safe
and but it is really really not so
enabling mtls should be the first step
on any new production cluster and I
recommend most people try Linker D it's
the easiest approach there are other
ones of course there's istio and there's
glue but Linker D from an operations
point of view it's just a Helm chart
away so yeah
now you mentioned um
default service accounts and compromised
pods having access to access access to
the cube API
I've
I would
haha good question
so the question was I mentioned the
default service account earlier this is
a token that is mounted into every
single part that allows you to query the
API server potentially and this was
actually removed and kubernetes 125 and
so there you will no longer get default
service accounts so default service
accounts mounted into any pod on Modern
kubernetes installations but all older
clusters do get this behavior
um I don't know why
I think you know it's been removed for a
reason when we don't want arbitrary part
has been able to speak to the apis
diverse so it's a really positive change
and we're seeing lots of changes like
this right and kubernetes for the last
two years I think every release is
bringing better defaults to kubernetes
clusters and we're taking security a lot
more seriously within the community
um you know with pod security policies
been deprecated but new runtime defaults
coming in we're seeing more adoption of
set comp like all these things are
coming and I think over the next two
years things will be much more seen by
default hopefully
no more
all right thank you for your time
[Applause]